inside of 10.  kevin porter jr milking the clock isoing  up top  now working on netto he'll dance he'll  step he'll shoot and he hits it at the  buzzer no time left and the rockets have  won the game  great stuff there by kevin porter jr  ryan after the great early start  and then  some issues in the middle  stephen silas trusted kevin coming off  the suspension to take the shot to win  the game and he delivered  all i can think about is the the bigger  picture here kevin porter jr going  through a really tough time in his life  um  seemingly you know had had some  questions off the court  and you saw that embrace from coach  steven silas and kevin porter jr and him  trusting kevin porter jr with the shot  that's why steven silas is the man for  this job